from each of our perspectives we are the
center of our own universe and there's
this thing as if you give you just we're
totally just seeing yourself from this
cosmic perspective you would lose your
your identity
[Music]
welcome to the Rubin report I'm Dave
Rubin and before I do anything else make
sure that you're still subscribed to our
channel and be sure to click the solid
Bell so they actually get notified when
we post new videos alright now that
that's out of the way joining me on the
Rubin report today is a futurist the
geopolitical expert an author of several
books including hacking Darwin genetic
engineering and the future of humanity
Jamie Metzl welcome to the Rubin report
thrilled to be here Dave I am glad to
have you here sir because I watched you
on Joe Rogan and I was like I've got to
talk to this guy about all of this crazy
futuristic stuff it's crazy our world is
changing and it's gonna change whether
we like it or not and better for people
to understand what's happening and be
part of the process of change rather
than just sit back and let it happen to
us all right so I'm pretty sure we're
gonna have a dense hour of exactly that
but before we get into the new book and
and really the the meat of all of this
how does one become a futurist you know
it's it's a funny question er it's that
there's a funny answer so for my whole
life
I've really been thinking about well
what's what's coming next when I was in
law school there were a group of us who
were who were thinking about what is the
information technology revolution going
to mean and this is the very early days
of the Internet than the World Wide Web
and we were thinking we were writing
about it and so they have a lot of
articles from those early days that were
imagining the world that we exist in
then more than 20 years ago I started
thinking and writing a lot about the
genetics revolution I never called
myself a futures I was just a guy who
was thinking about the future and I was
going around I do a lot of speaking at
various events and they're all these
people who were calling themselves
futurists I thought well that's kind of
it how did they become futurists so like
I'm writing I write about the future I
talk about the future right I assume
they were varying like sort of silver
monochrome exactly yeah like in the Devo
hat and so one day you know maybe I'm a
futurist and so I was being introduced
if it was something when you're speaking
this hey will you give us a short blurb
about about yourself and I put Jamie
Messel is a leading futurist and then
somebody gave this little card like that
and said Jamie Metzl is a leading
futurist and I became a sight I declared
myself leading I hope I can I could live
assist it's like one of these things
where I come from a family of doctors
like there's a day when you become a
doctor you kind of walk there they give
you the thing you shake your hands you
take a picture these are kind of self
declared titles and so for me I hope
that every day I am being judged by the
things that I'm writing and the things
that I'm saying all right this guy says
he's a futurist
other people are saying that he's a
futurist even though they're reading
words that he's himself has written is
he saying things that make sense is he
inspiring us to think differently about
the future I guess we'll find out in
about 55 days exactly let's go back a
little bit further though yeah to sort
of where that sparked within you because
my audience knows I'm a huge sci-fi guy
there are so many of the things that I
think about and I think believed to some
extent that I've learned through stories
in science fiction as a sci-fi writer
and as someone that is aventuras or at
least on your business card what were
some of the stories that excited you
when you were kid so it was just all of
these stories I mean these stories of
exploring space exploring humans I mean
we are because of the way our brains
function we learn through stories I mean
that's been probably the greatest
mechanism for the success of our species
is our ability to transfer information
to each other and we do it through this
medium of stories so just from when I
was a little kid I was a voracious
reader I read you know all the things
that the right that normal kids read I
loved Narnia I really I didn't realize
it was the whole Christian thing until
it was much much later but I just I just
read everything and I've always
gravitated to the world of stories and
even in that I have a big part of my
life that's nonfiction even in the
national security world
then it's about it's about stories
because what is what is the Cold War
what is anything it's it's a story that
we tell ourselves and then we organize
around those stories yeah I'm always
fascinated when people watch see
something or listen to something that
like just blows their mind and and just
puts them on a different track and one
of the things for me 1997 I ate some pop
brownies and I was going to see Air
Force One with a bunch of friends but it
was sold out yeah so we ended up walking
to into a movie called contact which
none of us had ever heard of we had no
idea what we were walking into and I'm
sure you've seen the movie contact and
it was written of course by Carl Sagan
right and that opening scene the
panorama of the universe and maybe it
was the pop brownies and I was just
right time my life I was 21 but my mind
was blown and from there I read almost
all I think of Carl Sagan's books and I
just opened my mind to that sort of
thing and that sort of you need in the
world that's why you need it's you know
from a cosmic perspective we are so
small I mean there are so many solar
systems and so many stars and so many
galaxies just if you try to think from
the perspective of the whole and then
you think we're just this one little
tiny planet pale blue nothing exactly
revolving around one star one Sun and
but but from each of our perspectives we
are the center of our own universe and
there's this thing as if you give you
just we're totally exist seeing yourself
from this cosmic perspective you would
lose your your identity but if we get so
caught up in our own little thing and
we're not able to see ourselves in this
greater context then also I think can be
dangerous or at least it can make us
less than we otherwise could be and
that's that's the role of stories I mean
stories help help situate ourselves
within ourselves within our communities
and within our world and our world
broadly defined which part of what you
do between talking about geopolitics and
dealing with the future stuff and you
know writing sci-fi and all these things
which one is sort of excites you the
most or is it just it's all of a piece
you know so definitely my big passion in
life is to translate big scary sometimes
complex ideas into language that can be
shared and so when I write novels I mean
that's the whole point of my of my
novels is to have people enter into a
world and that's what novelists do but
in the world what I'd like is people
enter into a world and maybe think a
little bit differently about themselves
about what it means to be a human about
how we're interacting with our
technology now with with hacking Darwin
I'm doing the same thing is that that
there is this all of this incredible
complexity of the genetics revolution
there's like really hard science that
not everybody is able to dig into but
what I want to do is to take all of that
and present it to people in ways that
they can see themselves in the story and
once we see ourselves in a story then we
can be part of it we can feel empowered
to have conversations to have opinions
because I think that's this this crazy
thing of this moment is that radical
technology but it's AI or genetics or
nanotechnology
quantum computing mean they're going to
change our lives in deep and fundamental
ways but people are scared of the
science and so there's this in some ways
it's like a helplessness that these
trends are coming and they're bigger
people feel that they're bigger than
they are and my message is is not just
that that's not the case and that's a
failure of the scientists I mean this
scientists need to be translating the
science so to bring other other people
along but science isn't its own thing it
doesn't exist in some kind of imaginary
objective realm science exists within
the context of our societies and if we
don't recognize that dynamic interaction
which means that everybody has a role to
play then we're going to have really
warped outcomes that are going to be bad
for society and they're also going to be
bad for science all right so then let's
jump into some of those big scary ideas
and let's just sort of do 101 couple
things because I think that's really
what you're trying to do here in a lot
of ways is just take a wider group of
people and get them to understand
something so it isn't so so big and
scary so let's just talk about the world
of genetics yeah
general right now yeah so when someone
says genetics for the person that has no
idea what we're talking about
great what are you talking about and
that person is my ideal audience I think
most people and they're sort of afraid
to admit it clear things frankly that
was what I loved my my interview with
Joe Rogan that's right no I think that's
why Joe Rogan is so successful in
addition to being a great guy because he
just he's this very confident as a
person but he's just asking common-sense
questions that the average person
probably would want to ask but when
they're when the average person
quote-unquote average person whoever
that is is faced with someone who's a
quote-unquote expert even a
self-declared futurist like me they're
kind of afraid of asking just some basic
questions they well what if what if it's
a bad question
maybe we all have that kind of events
agree so genetics so everybody everybody
I think understands vet genes that genes
are part of the the blueprint for life
and so to put it on a human level your
mother has an egg your father has a
sperm when that sperm fertilizes the egg
you have a fertilized egg it's a early
stage embryo it's one cell an egg and a
sperm that come together and in that
cell there is a blueprint for what
everything that you will become and so
that blueprint is written in a code and
that code is your genome and your genome
is made up of genes so it's a blueprint
for life let me let me pause it there
for a second so would you say at that
moment then once that coding is there is
that the beginning of what you would say
is life I mean this is this of course
where yes s assists and geneticists and
scientists and religious people have to
debate all these yes yes it's this is a
there's a political question which makes
it very difficult for us to it's very
difficult to think about that question
and just say well there's a scientific
question and there's a political
question because the whole thing is life
like is an egg cell alive yes our
ourselves alive yes is sperm Allah
yes but it's not on their own they're
not able to replicate which is one of
the hallmarks of life and so you could
say that that is the kernel of life
because life exists on a continuum it's
one microscopic cell but that cell if it
grows in the the quote-unquote normal
way it will it will become life so I
think that like I would never say that
the people who believe that life begins
at conception are wrong
imagining that it's because it's a
judgment call it's all on a continuum I
think that we can't say that but what I
would say is that there's a difference
between a single fertilized egg maybe
it's a single fertilized egg in a woman
or maybe it's in a lab like there's a
workout to that yeah and there's a
difference between that and like a baby
who's actually born and a a 20 year old
person I mean they're they're all the
politics of that but they certainly
there's no doubt that a single
fertilized egg is the beginning of of
life okay so we now live in a time when
we can start manipulating these genes
talk to me about that disease I know
that's the crazy moment that we are in
now so we have evolved for about 3.8
billion years so life most scientists
believe began from these thermal vents
and the bottom of the ocean this first
spark of life and so all of life on
Earth is related it comes from that same
spark of life and all of life of
ourselves plants everything else had
uses the same building blocks because we
have that same that same origin and for
almost four billion years we've evolved
by the Darwinian principles of random
mutation random mutation means just
we're all different and and that's
really important because if from whether
we're seeing when we were single-cell
organisms or anything if everybody is
the same it may be good now but if the
environment changes and you're still the
same then you're going to die and so the
kind of diversity is really is really
important so it's random mutation and
natural selection natural selection just
means we are in these competitive
environments and some formulations do
better than others I mean they're like a
million podcasts you're does a lot
better yeah than others and it's that is
a form of natural selection that there's
a marketplace and and a certain set of
attributes and if the world changes like
you maybe that we have no more
electricity and it's like or maybe we
get really there's no voice and the
people doing pantomime those are the
best podcasters I don't hear anything so
that's basically just the that is the
nature of reality as being change we
modify along the road yes arise so the
core principle is 3.8 billion years
driven by random mutation and natural
selection and now we are recognizing for
the first time one that all of biology
based on genetics is a form of
information technology and like our
traditional IT it is increasingly
readable and that's what genome
sequencing is and writable and hackable
and hackable meaning that we now have
these tools to edit the genome kind of
like a word processing we can eliminate
genes we can add genes and so we are
able to hack life and so we are
beginning after four billion years this
phase of our lives and our evolution
where we this one little group of
essentially monkeys that climb down from
the trees in Africa that we are a we
have the tools to recreate all of life
on Earth and it's this awesome power and
to quote spider-man it comes with a
tremendous responsibility technically
that was uncle then okay so so we have
this idea now that we can edit the
genome right we can read it we can edit
it and all of those things so before I
get to the sci-fi part of my brain which
is right where all the scary stuff comes
yeah yeah what are some of the good
things that we can be doing I'm so glad
you asked that because I yeah I speak
about this stuff all the time and
I could speak for an hour 58 minutes it
like here all these miraculous things
it's so exciting but and then fill a
stream it's like they're just some
potential downsides we need to be
mindful of right and it's like at the
end people say like oh my god I'm so
depressed we're all gonna die so we
should be incredibly excited about this
revolution because it's going to help us
a ton so the first the most the
immediate impact is going to be how it
changes our experience of healthcare
right now we live in a world of
generalized healthcare based on
population averages so you go to a
doctor and you get treated based on
being a human if you have a headache
maybe you get a Tylenol but you find out
if you're one of the people who dies
from time I'll by taking a Tylenol
because it's everything is based on on
the odds of most people will respond to
a certain treatment it's the same true
the same is true for about 88% of cancer
treatments we're now moving to a world
of precision medicine and so precision
medicine means that you're treated not
just based on your being a human but
based on your being you so any
intervention is going to be based on
your individual biology so they
literally are going to be able to look
at your your genome is that the right
word well there's the genome so there'll
be a set of information so it'll be your
personal history your family history
your biometric information other
measurements and your your genetic
information but your genetic information
will be the most significant foundation
of your electronic health record and
that information will be provided mostly
at birth
them so we're all going to be sequenced
at justjust like when you get a Hugh and
a kid is born they do a blood test with
a heel prick mmm everybody in the not
just in future will have their whole
genome sequence and that will just be
part of their electronic health record
and so the exciting thing is one
everyone's going to get these this
personalized medicine and it will be
better medicine because it'll be
tailored for all of our biology but even
more significant we're going to have
billions of people whose genetic and
life information are in these massive
data sets and
we're going to be able to use big data
analytics to increasingly unlock the
secrets of genetic and information and
systems biology meaning that we have
systems of systems inside of our of our
biology and what that is going to mean
is we're going to have a lot of
information not just about why you may
be sick now but about how your life is
likely to play out from the moment of
birth you're going to know that I have a
greater than average risk of this
genetic disease for example and that's
going to be very actionable because if
you're a woman and you know that you
have let's say a 70% greater than
average chance of getting breast cancer
you're going to want to start your
screenings much earlier than somebody
who doesn't have that predisposition but
we're also going to have a lot of
information that it's not deterministic
but is probabilistically predictable
about certain things that have nothing
to do with health like IQ the genetic
component of IQ personality style may be
that we have a great potential to be a
fantastic sprinter or mathematician and
we're going to have to think very very
differently about parenting and about
life and a lot of this stuff can be
scary but it's very what it's also
exciting like imagine you right now we
have these terrible refugee camps all
over the world but we have Einsteins in
every one of those camps and we just
don't know who they are we do in Los
Angeles where we are now I mean there
are these inner cities and the crime of
inner cities I mean there's all kinds of
problems but it's just like we're
throwing human potential down the toilet
so people are worried about be about
genetic profiling and they should be
worried but what about all these people
who were throwing away if we knew that
that some kid who's like growing up in
terrible conditions like has this
incredible potential and who knows
whether any potential will be realized
to be like a genius musician or
mathematician even we would at least
think twice about not providing
resources to help people realize their
potential it's so interesting because as
you're saying all this and I can think
of all of the row
that we undo good things they have just
laid out there and then there's this
other part of me and maybe that just is
the the sci-fi dystopian part where you
think of all the ways that there could
be evil manipulations and population
control and eugenics and all all of
these things that seem wrong or just in
the wrong hands could could go up you
know just completely haywire but so do
you view that sort of choice yes I do
you view that as different than with any
other technology now or is this sort of
unique it's it's not different in that
every technology has their utopian and
dystopian potential uses what's unique
here is that this technology is so
powerful and it's coming at us so
quickly that we don't have the same time
that we've had to figure it out like
with steam I mean steam and electricity
and and even the using gasoline I mean
all these things they were revolutionary
but we had a little bit of time to
transition and this is the problems that
the science is moving so quickly that
the transitions like can't happen in the
kind of methodical ways and as
disruptive as they've been in the past
but there that will that will be much
more methodical than what's coming and
that's why we're there's a race and and
so every one of these technologies every
good outcome has a parallel story that's
a bad outcome and so for me I tend to be
all-in-all net-net
optimistic but the the technology itself
is agnostic and what's at play now is
the question of what are the values that
we are going to use to guide this
technology and I think that's that's the
game and that's what I'm trying to bring
people into the conversation to say that
if you are worried about a potential
dystopian outcome how can we fight
together to make sure that that doesn't
happen how can we bring people into the
conversation to say our well here's what
I want to see I want to have these
technologies used in ways that are
making our communities stronger that are
enhancing human potential in positive
ways but to do it we all need to have a
voice and to have a voice we need to be
educated are there people that just
focus on the speed
portion of this because for some reason
that really fascinates me like this
whole thing does but something this idea
that people all over the globe now
because of the internet and all the
other ways we're connected can all be
working on these things all at the same
time all be you know sort of jumping in
front of each other and faster and
faster ways and for all we know there's
all sorts of technologies happening in
China now that we have no idea about and
I want to relate this also yeah of
course to the geopolitical part which is
some countries are gonna have more
restrictions right on these technologies
and some won't and all of these things
so the speed part to me is just really
fast it's an essential piece of this
story just think about this that you
know a hundred years ago 500 years ago
there were the same distribution of
geniuses that we have now but if you're
a genius 500 years ago somewhere in
Africa or somewhere in Asia you're kind
of on your own right you know Ramanujam
this kind of genius mathematician in
India he had like one book I mean he's
either from that one book he kind of
figured out this this incredible system
of math but now if you're a genius most
anywhere in the world like you have
access to the global library you don't
have to be in the Bronze Age the Copper
Age we had all these people all around
the world who are having the same
discoveries basically over in the same
pattern without being connected to each
other at all it's kind of a waste of
energy once a big copper got it it's not
right I'm just sending out the email
right right so Thomas said is it figure
something out and some guy halfway
across the world doesn't realize though
you know months ago that what a waste of
energy said oh no you don't know buddy
we're all interconnected so everybody
you don't you don't start at the bottom
of the mountain you start kind of 2/3 of
the way up the mountain and you don't
have to take a step that has been taken
by somebody else you don't have to solve
a problem that has been taken that has
been solved by somebody else and so with
Peter and everybody in the world
increasingly being brought into this
process we are unleashing this
imaginative
creative tidal wave that I just think
that people don't appreciate the
significance of that and that's why you
in this field of biotech and and
genetics pretty much every day there's
another paper that comes out that nobody
notices but if this same paper had come
out ten years ago everyone is world
changers everyone would have gotten the
Nobel Prize right there's like there's a
Nobel Prize ever like every sink no
garage worthy discovery in the context
of ten years ago every single day right
so okay so I think most people
understand the part that if we can if we
can map your genetics that then we can
watch out and know that you shouldn't
take this medicine or you should stay
away from this food or that sort of
thing so it's sort of a blueprint for
sort of how you can live and how you can
flourish yeah most maximally yeah and
yeah to identify so right now when you
have a dizzy you have a symptom and you
go to the doctor and then the doctor
tries to treat that symptom but maybe
this is a symptom something that's been
germinating in you for a decade maybe
it's something that results from a
genetic abnormality that you had since
the moment when you were that that
single cell that fled fertilized egg and
so it's going to change our model of
healthcare then from treatment of
symptoms to prevention so I think that's
and that's so doing all of those things
but in a way that's personalized for you
is I'm going to know I have a risk of
this certain outcome I don't want that
outcome to happen and so here are the
things that I'm going to do from the
beginning so that then gets us to the
editing portion of this right so okay so
now we know that you're predisposed to
XY and Z now we can start editing things
right to make sure that you are not
going to get surgery yes so what you're
talking about is editing that happens
after you're born and so there's a big
distinction between these two kinds of
editing
there's germline editing which I know
we'll talk about which is editing two
sex cells and so that's primarily
embryos but also it works on sperm and
eggs and the reason why it's called
germline is it that's when you edit the
sex cells the sperm cells
the sperm eggs or embryo then that gets
passed on to future generations but if I
edit you or an adult not in the sex
cells then that's just for that person
over the course of their life and that's
why it's less controverts controversial
but it's less controversial so there's a
whole class of interventions called gene
therapies that are used to do exactly
that and right now for example cancer is
probably the best the best example so
there are a lot of people who have
cancer we all have these natural
antibodies that fight cancers but
sometimes people there they're
antibodies aren't working well enough
and sometimes they have a cancer that
just is is overpowering their antibody
so there's a treatment called Carty
therapy where you take out somebody's
blood cells and you genetically engineer
them to give to boost their natural
cancer fighting superpowers then you put
those cells back into the person's body
and that person becomes a genetic
superheroes this is sort of like
platelet-rich therapy right yes apipa is
a much narrower much less systemic
intervention so yes but this is that
kind of quote-unquote yeah and so so we
are going to be in and so there's a
delivery so when the delivery is
happening through blood that makes it a
little bit a little bit easier but then
we have all kinds of what are called
specialized cells so you stop when you
in use doing your that single-cell
organism or single cell pre implanted
embryo you can't have the potential to
become everything but your cells
differentiate over time and that's why
you can have skin cells and liver cells
and heart cells and so when we're doing
these kinds of interventions for gene
therapies we're wanting to edit a
specific kind of cell what let's call it
a heart cell or something like that and
so there need to be delivery mechanisms
to do it and so when it's blood you can
easily take it out and put it back but
now there's all this whole other area of
research of using basically retrofitted
viruses because viruses for billions of
years have developed a machinery to kind
of infiltrate our bodies
and replicate so we take advantage of
that to deliver certain kinds of gene
edits to specific parts of the body to
treat specific types of problems and
that's not that's not fully ready for
primetime with humans there are some
very early clinical trials a huge amount
of work those is happening in this area
I don't know if this is exactly the I'd
point to mention this so where does
CRISPR fall into so CRISPR is the the
the among the best forms of gene editing
so if you have the genome and you're
making the changes at the genome there
needs to be a mechanism for doing that
and so there have been prior tools for
gene editing that were much slower and
more expensive than this tool of CRISPR
and it's called CRISPR caste 9 is the
most prominent but there are many so
basically there are these repeating
patterns in the genome and with the
CRISPR systems they can identify use a
guide RNA to find a specific place on
the genome and then with the caste 9
it's a cutting enzyme so you think
that's the double helix you go to a
place and then you have this little
knife molecular scissors and you cut out
what you don't want and then this the
the the genome will either reconnect
with that missing piece gone or you can
introduce an additional piece of DNA
designed to fit in that little space and
they'll be it'll be like oh we're
missing a piece of this bridge oh here
it is and that the cell will just
naturally put it there so I sense we're
getting into one of those places where
the average person is suddenly going
whoa whoa I'm losing it a little bit so
to unwind this a little bit though
because I think I think we've got the
right pieces yeah that doing all of that
then would allow people to be again
inoculated from certain diseases to be
able to maximize health and also for
generations then after to be able to you
know so why not have to deal with these
things let me make it very visual and
and concrete so I'm a member of the
World Health Organization has an
International Advisory Committee on
human genome editing which we were
created
at the end of last year 2018
after a Chinese scientist announced in
November that the world's first gene
edited babies had been secretly born in
China in October 2018 so these this
tools of using these CRISPR system to
change basically they edited these pre
implanted embryos of these two little
girls and what they did was went in and
they basically disrupted this one gene
which is called ccr5 no one needs to
remember ccr5 but just the genes just
all have different different names and
what the ccr5 gene when it's disrupted
people have disrupted copies of ccr5
mostly Northern Europeans have an
increased resistance to HIV because the
HIV virus can't penetrate into this into
the cell and so this was way way before
people thought and myself included
thought it was safe it felt like human
experimentation but these kids were were
born and so the world's first gene
edited babies are born and people go
straight from that and it's a huge deal
I think it was highly unethical of this
guy to do and then they they say are
well then the next step in people's mind
is it's like the you know then you know
the build-a-bear workshop we just like
right you just like I'll take one of
these one of these one of these and it's
not going to be that biology is too
complex for that but we are increasingly
going to have the capacity and it's
still it's the very very early days but
it's going to be more and more and more
to begin making a small number of gene
edits to potential future humans and
that's a really big deal so what was the
ethical conundrum there just because
this is still too untested yeah so so a
few things one it was just way premature
I mean it's a lot of people are doing
experiments on animals like mice but to
do these experiments on real live humans
I mean we know what I mean that that is
to me it's like we have the nerve
conventions about what is in is not okay
in this felt experimental do so and we
know for a fact that this has been done
it this has been verified in other
places or it could this possibly just be
a situation where I you know I if
there's a one percent chance okay that
this is a fraud in my view there's a 99%
chance that it is not a fraud and I know
a lot of people that I work with people
who know this know this guy ho-jon Quay
is his name so I think it's it I'm
entirely convinced that it's did Israel
but it was unethical because it was
premature
because it was totally untransparent
because the work was sloppy because the
parents didn't forgive their proper
consent and because the target was a
wrong one in the sense that these kids
the father had HIV the mother didn't but
the kids would not have been born with
HIV had this not happened so he was now
I wasn't treating something that they
had he was trying to give them and
enhancement wait how do we know that
they wouldn't have been born with HIV is
that just not how it transmits in that
so we have all kinds of technologies
like washing sperm that make it so that
if you are a man with HIV in the United
States and you want to have a baby with
a woman who doesn't have HIV it's it
there are lots and lots of ways okay you
will get that you'll you will have a
baby if you if you get proper care that
doesn't have HIV so it's not like these
kids were going to have HIV they weren't
and so one is although there's not a
clear line between therapy and
enhancement this was clearly an
enhancement and my thought is we will be
enhancing ourselves in the future and
probably in the future we should be
enhancing cuz it's just like we're a
we're buggy we've evolved over billions
of years evolution has made all kinds of
trade-offs and sometimes those
trade-offs are bad for us individually
and so it's terrible when people die
young of terrible genetic diseases it's
terrible when old people get demand
and lose their minds I don't want that
if we can make little tweaks that we've
figured out I'd say like all power to us
like why not that's the history of our
of our species we need to be careful but
for here for the first step on using
this incredibly powerful technology on a
human it would have been more
responsible if we had done it five years
from now in a very responsible very
transparent way addressing a target
where there would have been a kid would
have otherwise been born with a deadly
genetic disease and then we would have
had like here in the beginning you said
let's talk about the good stuff and then
we'll talk about the scary stuff it's
better to start with the good stuff
because people are primed to be
terrified and so I just would have been
so much better had we done it that well
that's why I'm so fascinated with the
speed part of it yes because it's sort
of like well somewhere maybe in China
but somewhere there's gonna be an island
of dr. Moreau sort of thing where just
some scientist who doesn't you know who
just wants to do whatever he can with
you and you know let the consequences be
damned we'll go ahead and do it and it
won't you know for years that could
exist and no one will know and then you
know the more responsible scientists
will constantly be playing catch-up and
then that also sort of brings me to the
law part of this because we are starting
sort of to discuss laws around this here
a little bit barely barely I mean I
remember when george w bush was sort of
talking about some of this we related to
stem cells and that sort of thing yeah
but how much of this do you think will
come down to just what countries will
sort of allow it more versus what
scientists are just gonna do with them
yeah it's a great question it's an
essential question that's the race
because the science is moving forward
exponentially you're exactly right it
was not a surprise that the the first I
write about this in the book that the
first application of using CRISPR gene
editing on humans happened in China I've
always said that's where it's going to
happen it's not a surprise that now it's
in Russia that there's a biologist there
who's saying he has five people lined up
to have more genetically engineered
babies and this happens all this
technology exists within the context of
our societies and so there are some
societies that are bei
better regulated in these areas I always
hold up the United Kingdom as kind of
the gold standard they have a national
healthcare system which makes it much
more it much easier to just spread
rationality in the system where we had
in the US we have this kind of this
chaotic system a system of a system is
the part of the problem in my audience
it's not a big rig regulation guys so
it's part of the problem though that
even if you have regulation well done
well intentioned all that that in a way
that will slow down certain advancements
where then the bad guys let's say or the
or the kooky scientists who who don't
have those ethical dilemmas yes will
just keep making jumps in a faster
faster way yeah but we don't it's not
unlike regulation is good or bad we need
the right amount of regulation to
incentivize the outcomes that we want
and especially in an area like this
where we're talking about the future of
human life the the you you talked about
where does life begin at conception
which is a very legitimate issue a lot
of people feel emotional about it and
the people who are saying life begins at
conception they're not saying life
begins at conception but let's have no
regulations and life begins at
conception for me they're saying what we
need to have a regulatory system by laws
so to determine what people can and
can't do and I may disagree with with
some of the goals that they're setting
but I think we're all agreeing that this
needs to be you this is life and it has
to be regulated and we don't want
scientists out there just experimenting
on humans which is what happened in in
China right and so that's what I'm
saying I'm with you on that but that we
can't regulate all countries yeah what
we need to do with like if any society
decide oh we're just gonna opt out of
this of this technology like opting out
of the genetics revolution is opting out
of national competitiveness in the 21st
century
like if you do it you can do it but you
are just going to be like you're not
going to have a competitive economy
because this is the future it's it is
you're gonna be like when we find those
random tribes somewhere yeah which is
great and they're probably happier than
we are
édouard they're working out your steps a
day that's a whole topic so what we need
to do is we need to find that balance
within our within our societies and it's
a it's good to have that balance because
like with the United Kingdom they're
very well regulated they have
cutting-edge science but the public is
on board with the science and so we
United States we have incredible science
we have the best basic science in the
world but there's this total mismatch
between the science that's racing
forward and the general public which is
kind of afraid and and is is cautious
why we're doing this exactly NOAA and so
we need to find a way of bringing those
people together now I'm going to do an
interview on Newt Gingrich's radio show
and I'm so committed to engaging with
religious communities evangelical
communities conservative communities
because it's like it wouldn't it be
terrible say oh like oh no this is my
truth that's your truth we can't even
talk to each other that's the the
foundation of society but you're
absolutely right there are some places
that are going to be that already are
less regulated or maybe well regulated
based on a different set of values you
can imagine a place like North Korea so
we want to leave the leaders why we want
to stay in power forever and so we'd
like to engineer certain outcomes that
will have a Plato's Republic model or
have the leaders and then we'll have the
followers and we'll select their embryos
or maybe even do some basic gene editing
to determine certain outcomes and so
there's a race and there's a race
between societies but there's also a
race to see can we build some kind of
normative global system that can at
least bring us all together with a
process and there's a lot of examples of
failure but there's if there's some
examples whether its nuclear weapons
chemical weapons biological weapons even
climate change where we've not succeeded
but we've done certainly better than
worse and the entire we talked about
telling stories I mean international law
is a story the concept of human rights
is a story and we've sold those stories
pretty well and that's what we need to
do and then that's why we need to work
on the
individual level everyone needs to be
educated on the national level we need
smart laws and we need political leaders
who are engaged on this issue which is
hardly the case now and on an
international system where we need to
move towards having processes that can
bring us together and over time develop
nor norms and regulations and laws ok so
we sort of understand the inequity let's
say between the way certain nations are
gonna deal with this and the way certain
individual scientists are going to deal
with this let's jump into that religious
portent of it for a moment so I'm glad
you're gonna go talk to and you can't
I've got them coming on in the oh good
and he said look it's interesting to
talk to a Republican who I think you
know basically I think has a pretty
decent understanding yeah I ins but
comes from a religious perspective as
well ok that's fine it's essential well
what do we do not talk to each other so
so when you talk to it yeah nude or even
even not to make it so specifically a
bit about nude but when you talk to
people of faith yeah I think the first
roadblock you're gonna come against is
they're just gonna say you're playing
God I mean yeah sure you hear this all
the time so how do you how do you
counter that or how do you wage their
fears yeah yeah so first the first thing
is acknowledging it's like I get that
fear I share that fear I mean whether
it's playing God or messing with complex
systems that we don't fully understand I
mean this is the this is a hubris t'k
Act we are just one little species in a
world of may millions of species like
who says that we are the ones who get to
recreate life and so I get it
but if you believe that is OK for humans
to apply technology to change our
environments the question is and should
we or shouldn't we because that's what
we do that's why we're here that's what
medicine is that's what agriculture is I
mean we live in a world that we have
transformed through our art technology
the question is what are the uses of
that technology that we are that we're
comfortable with and I get that this
issue of abortion is very difficult it's
very painful for for people and I'm not
a proponent of abortion
I just feel that a woman should have the
right within limits to dictate what
happens to her own body I don't think
this date basically can enforce slavery
on women to force them to carry children
on behalf of the state which is
essentially what what what it would be
but like even with the people who are
the the corn quit pro-life people in the
context of the debates that we just had
in Alabama mm-hmm
there were people who were leading that
people in the state Senate in Alabama
they very consciously decided to leave
IVF out of that legislation mm-hmm so if
you believe that life begins at
conception when that sperm fertilizes
the egg that is life and that's
inviolable you would say well we should
include IVF right has been there not
doing it because in the every community
when you see these parents whether
they're high-risk parents or older
parents or soon just normal parents who
are having children through IVF it's the
miracle of life and so the quote from
from one of the Alabama senators well
we're not applying this doesn't apply to
those fertilized eggs in a dish we're
talking about about about embryos inside
of a woman's body so that's a real
disconnect there yeah you could call it
a disconnect but I'm not calling it a
disc I'm saying it's a recognition that
this stuff is really complicated and if
we just say I have this absolute
position and and I'm just gonna stick to
it I think that's going to like I want
to look for to say why well you have
recognized that because you are pro-life
you recognize that you want to protect
embryos and we may have political
differences but I respect yours and you
want to protect the miracle of life of
these these people in your communities
who are having kids through IVF that
they otherwise wouldn't have and so I
just think we have to work towards
finding some kind of con are we ever
going to completely agree no but no
no that's not a standard in a democracy
it's not you have to agree on everything
is that how do we rebuild a place where
we can at least communicate with each
other and try to find as much common
ground as possible so there's so many
ways I could go with this yeah and I
have a zillion sci-fi movies rattling in
their head yes suddenly I had something
about Star Wars in there related to
basically a clone army we'd started
having this genetically modified group
of humans versus we haven't even got
into robotics at all nerve but AI
Androids and they're gonna sort of be
rising but let me let me hold that one
yeah for for just a sec what about the
economic portion of this which is that
once these technologies become more
ubiquitous and more people can afford
them and then then then they're just
sort of out there and some of that
mainstream but obviously like every
other technology like a flat-screen
television you know people that have the
means will start using them and that
basically we're gonna sort of have two
paths for humans there'll be sort of
these superhumans who will be able to
deal with all of these things and take
advantage of these technologies and then
you'll have the regular old suckers like
us right now that can't do it and that
what what we're gonna do with that how
we're gonna sort of bridge that divide
it's it's a really essential essential
question a few different ways of
answering it one is that's one
possibility and if we let that happen
shame on us because the technology isn't
requiring that outcome it's the way we
have decided to organize ourselves so in
a country like Israel where IVF is
included in the National Health Plan you
don't have these these these equity
issues because everybody has access and
if you have a system where you're doing
that it actually would pay for itself
because we're going to be able to
prevent huge numbers of genetic diseases
that are costing us many many hundreds
of billions of dollars so that's an
organizational issue no I always say
that if people are worried about genetic
inequality in the future as we should be
we can wait until the future comes to
say like a high this was where you look
at the world today and say jeez there's
so much inequality today
person kid born in the Central African
Republic is born essentially brain
damaged because of mounted metal
malnutrition in the context of the Civil
War and so there's no difference in
terms of outcome between a genetically
enhanced person and me or my kids and my
kids and a kid born in the Central
African Republic there's still that same
differential but if we're okay with that
today if we're not living those values
today how can we sell but in the future
we want to live those values when we are
the people in the Central African
Republic and the second point I'll
quickly make is we all have these
superpowers that once seemed like magic
so we're all and most hopefully
immunized or most of us are immunized
not how much anymore it's like a
superpower
yeah and it's a zoom route that
everybody has so there's also a cost
issue with this ok so let's so basically
there's a that's the political element
to this that's sort of the so what do
you do I mean how do you know how do you
get politicians to get on board things
that are such big ideas that you know
politicians when they talk about
anything now we've been dumbed down to
the point where it's like yeah you're
gonna mention CRISPR and it's gonna make
sense that'd be like how do you actually
get the political elite to be able to
deal with this so anonymous way then the
honest answer is I don't know yeah I'm
just trying here the here are the things
that at least I'm trying to do one is
I'm trying to help people get educated
and so with this book I've written it's
it's really at a level that anybody can
can understand and I want to just bring
people in to the end like once you have
basic information we're all equals
because we're all humans and everyone
has to say to where I'm doing a lot of
outreach to political leaders we've
offered the copies of the e-book for
free to any member of parliament of any
country in the whole world
talking with actually brad sherman is a
congressman from los angeles and and
others about congressional hearings in
the paperback version of hacking Darwin
which is coming out in April we're gonna
have a short political guide in the end
with some some pointers about how to
questions to ask for your political
leaders and I'm doing this this work in
in Geneva but all of that amounts to
nothing in the sense that what we need
is we need a 10x
loschen like everybody we need on a
popular level people need to be seized
with this she's kind of like it's
happened with climate change I mean
climate change 10 years ago was a
non-issue and now you know people are
whether it's not using plastic straws or
you're marching or where people get that
this is an issue people get that they
want to have their voices heard we need
to have that happen and with issues of
genetics and now will at least begin to
put this on the radar of political
leaders but then we need to educate
political leaders like we need to have
outreach and this is I talked about this
in in the book you every movement has to
start somewhere it has to start from
this little little hopeless place where
like there's this huge problem and
there's just a few a few people but if
we need it's a it's a political issue
and the issue the challenge is 10 years
from now this is going to be the biggest
issue in the world everyone's going to
be talking about they're going to be
people marching I think there's a
potential of violence because the people
who are if you're worried about
genetically modified crops now how are
you gonna feel about Jennifer modified
humans so but why wait 10 years until
this is like an exploding crisis to have
a conversation about one of the things
that we should be doing now because big
decisions are being made every day yeah
so when you talk about genetically
modified humans I'll go to one of the
sci-fi movies did you ever see the
island I can't believe I'm gonna quote a
Michael Bay movie no but it's it's I
think it was maybe it was a philip k
dick story right but basically the idea
being that these sort of rich elite
people could clone themselves and so
that if any F at any point they got into
a car accident or had a disease that
they basically had all the parts
available and then of course what
happens is the clones believe that they
are human and right and that's what the
right the debate comes about but but all
that's not that far from what we could
become reality right healing as a
science fiction writer and recognize
that we live in this world of
exponential change where are our sense
of the speed of change is too
conservative because we understand it
that just because the way our brains
function by looking backwards mm-hmm
whereas change is happening going
forwards is going to be a lot a lot
faster all kinds of crazy things not
everything but all kinds of crazy things
that we can
imagine could or will become real and so
that's so there are a lot of different
scenarios certainly human biology is
extremely complex and so it's going to
take us a long time to understand more
of this incredible complexity but our
the this the complexity of our biology
has been roughly consistent for millions
of years but the sophistication of our
tools is on a J curve and so we are
going to be using big data analytics and
all of these other incredibly powerful
tools to understand ourselves and we're
going to be able to look under the hood
of what it means to be human there will
still be this wonderful mystery yeah but
we're going to know a lot more we're
gonna have to figure out how to use that
knowledge in ways that doesn't undermine
our humanity but makes us individually
and collectively better that could be
the ending but I want to go a little bit
more so going back to what I mentioned
before this sort of somewhat silly Star
Wars thing but this idea of clones that
we can genetically modify their
conditions and all of these things and
now you have AI growing is there sort of
a split within the Futurist community of
what people think is maybe one is more
the future than the other or something
like that there are some people who are
that that it's genetically engineered
humans and their summit is going to be
AI and in my very very strong view it
can't be one or the other it's it's
humans plus AI garry kasparov writes
about this and that's that is the thing
cuz we are humans are incredible our
brain is so unbelievably almost
magically sophisticated all the things
that they can do are just so way beyond
the possibility even though even of our
most advanced AIS
and so we need to find ways that we will
work together genetics revolution is the
AI revolution there would be no way that
without our AI and big data analytics
that we could even begin to to decode
the incredible complexity of our of our
biology so the two really need to work
together not only this
the 21st century is to figure out what a
what do humans do that machines can't do
and what a machines do the humans can't
do or just if are better at the diamonds
and how do we pull those capabilities
together and then with these massively
powerful capabilities how do we try to
build some guardrails to make sure that
our technology is used to advance our
best values rather than undermine them
okay so we'll end on this I'll give you
the scariest question I possibly could
which is 20 years from now if if the 98%
that you usually focus on the good stuff
at the talks right if that really works
paint me what that future looks like and
then we'll go to the other sure so that
one is we're going to be living longer
we're going to be living healthier we're
going to have all kinds of information
about future risks and potentials and
we're going to use that in a positive
way to inform our lives if we have risks
a down the line we're going to be
working to minimize those risks we're
going to change the way that we make
babies we're going to increasingly move
from conception through sex to
conception through IVF followed by
embryo screening right now in the u.s.
we have about two percent of kids are
born through IVF in Japan it's five
percent in Norway and Denmark it's ten
percent those numbers are always going
to go up and still until we see
procreation by sex is something that is
not natural and then we're also going to
be I can't believe I'd even mentioned
this whole time we're also gonna be then
growing humans in labs too you know
that's a debate now so there this is
this whole movement for artificial wombs
mm-hmm there's a lot that happens
emotionally and biologically we've seen
a mother and a baby but certainly it's
it's working for sheep and so they're
basically the core point is that biology
is at play we have this sense though we
I know what volatile biology is because
I'm a human and my parents were humans
but a lot of these things are just at
play I mean we were single-cell
organisms and now we're this and we're
going to be something else and that's
something else will be impacted by our
technology just like you are our
digestive system has been guided by fire
like FISA allows us to digest things
that otherwise we could
and so we are like that is where we're
going and then just this this 20 years
story so we're gonna be better
healthcare moving away from sex from
conception through sex and we're going
to be begin selecting future children
based on health outcomes and other
information about traits now give me the
2% we screw this thing up what are we
looking at we are attacking each other
that there's a level of social cohesion
that is required for this technology to
advance in ways that benefit everybody
one of the reasons why we're having so
many problems here in the United States
is that we had this economic change so
we had this change in in basically the
role of capital in society so capital
was overvalued and labor was undervalued
we allowed this small group of people to
amass just a disproportionately
disproportionate and inappropriate
amount of power and then everybody else
maybe they couldn't articulate all the
reasons that does have this something
hey I'm getting screwed over hmm and I'm
gonna fight back
and so if this powerful technology if we
don't handle it in a responsible way
we're gonna be at each other's throats
we're going to have elites who are
saying you know screw this like my
mission in life is to create advantages
and confer advantages to the to my
children I have more in common with
people who are wanting to do that in
other countries all around the world
then I do with these other people in my
country who are just causing there's a
pain in my ass and they're demanding
things and they're fighting against
things that I want so I'm just leaving I
mean my crops are basically they're
gonna have to build Elysium or something
just or something or just you know you
very just you know take have an island
do it in the Caribbean or or whatever so
if we're not careful on these
technologies could destroy our societies
and that's why I mean this is a
conversation it's teed up by science but
it's the core pillar is values I mean
that's what this is all about
I would love to continue this yes we got
a wrap but as you may know I go off the
grid for August so today we're taping
this right now at the end of July right
and I'm disappearing no technology no
phone and nothing electronic
and so you've teed me up for so much
good stuff to think about where are you
going I hope I'm not telling but I'm
just I'm disappearing and there will be
nothing electronic and it's it's so
important because we're talking about
this this technology and technology it
does so many wonderful things but at the
core if we lose the essence of what it
just means to be a human gesture but out
in the mountains it's like that's
everything yeah I have thoroughly
enjoyed this I hope you'll come back to
Iowa together back in the prediction I I
would love I'll come back in might the
paperback version of hacking garments
coming out in April of next year
and so I'd love to come back when that
happens done and all right thank you
very much and for more on Jaime you can
follow him on Twitter at Jamie Mets oh
and if you enjoy conversations like
these don't forget to subscribe and
click the bell so that you actually get
notified of the videos thanks for
watching
[Music]